need motivation what's the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
high-performance wisdom from Dane pina
to give you the motivation confidence
and belief that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one focus focus focus I focus on
everything I mean I focus on one thing
at a time most of you are engaged in 2
or 3 or 4 different endeavors and you're
not doing any of them very well focus on
one and I never get into business I'm
not looking to exit by the way I said it
yesterday for those of you and I've read
to be me or him a couple of you you have
a business the two years ago and now
you're doing 250,000 or 260,000 euros in
revenue that's geometric growth you
started from 0 24 months ago you're now
doing 250,000 euros that's geometric
growth but now what did I said yesterday
you started playing not to lose instead
of playing to win focus I mean and it's
it's it's a single key thing when you're
an athlete and I was an athlete by any
stretch of the imagination but the
world-class athlete I've had the
privilege of working with all the same
thing focus if they're basketball
players and I had a pleasure of working
with the Lakers back in their heyday
they wake up they go to sleep with the
basketball literally football is they
going to sleep I mean from the time they
get up to the time they go to bed that's
all they think about its focus rule
number 2 expose yourself to high
performance people I had a nursery
mother but I had a dad that kicked the
[ __ ] out of me beat me like a rented
mule
and if my father were still alive and I
have uncles and they'd say Manny you're
too hard on Danny and he would say just
as he looked into the camera and said my
son success well not because I maybe but
in spite of me
he looked them in the eye since how's
your program working out with your
crackhead poor daughter because when
they compared me no matter how much I
did wrong my success I don't know
anything other than dropping the ball in
center field which I have nightmares
about to this day I've only had success
and when you've only had success all
your life I make money by accident
I don't know failure I just don't and
it's infectious and you start not
hanging our children exposing and not
exposing yourself in a sexual way
exposing you shy gotta be careful about
all these words up and you start
exposing yourself to high performance
people I mean and you will forget how to
be a loser you'll forget how to be a
loser rule number three don't care what
others say some people will never like
me and I will never give up you worry
about what they say as I told Brian Rose
many years four years ago you have no
idea how limitless your life becomes
visa vie goals when you don't give a
[ __ ] what people think say or whisper
about you you have no idea the world
will not value me until I value myself
and the reason why people don't value
kids is because you don't value yourself
companies does not they will like me
competences I'll be fine if they don't
like me now it's safe to say that I've
never been worried about what people
think of me that's a truth that's the
truth
rule number four the old Bing Jeff is
worth about 150 billion dollars the
founder of Amazon this is what he looked
like almost 20 years ago
twenty years ago they lasted him 20
years ago he wasn't with $20,000 let
alone 150 billion now he's got to come a
company roughly speaking around a
trillion dollars little less maybe 150
billion less because of the sell-off in
the market etc but they laughed it and
he had an idea he had a dream like him I
had a dream about 35 years ago I am the
first person on a planet it took an
option for something he did not own on a
major Stock Exchange
I might say okay I don't own that book
right
I paid him $1 on the national TV five
dollars for that book I hear from now
I took an option I took that but not
don't eat it and I sold it on the New
York Stock Exchange
for 150 million bucks that's what I did
and that was the beginning of my quantum
leap if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series they are free
the links to join are in the description
below you want people with a like mind
and that are better than you smarter
than you more intelligent than you to
get on your bus but knowing guys know
initially upfront you have to try you
have to swing at the plate a kid like
you if you had to keep track of seven
days a week 24 hours a day what you do
rule number five work hard when I first
went to work for Wall Street firm in
1972 the they didn't really have any
formal sales program training programs
and so what they did is they they give
you the yellow pages call everybody in
the yellow pages and when you got
through the yellow pages call everybody
in the white pages and then when you got
down for the white pages you called you
co called every building that had more
than ten stories on Wall Street well
every building on Wall Street has ten
stories and so you got to kiss a lot of
frogs paying you before you're going to
find a customer
and you got to turn over a lot of rocks
there was 25 years straight from 1991 to
1996 I didn't take a day off
25 years straight 1991 471 to 1996 71
tonight I didn't take a day off rule
number six believe two months ago when
we were working I signed a deal for a TV
show a few weeks ago and they were doing
research and we discovered that where I
lived in 1972 on 27th and Lexington when
I first went to Wall Street now been
torn down we used to call the building
the bedbug probably some of you live in
the bedbug now and then 12 years later I
was living in the castle 12 years yes
was a castle on my my affirmations yes
was a castle on my gold yes was a castle
in my prayers yes but I thought the
castle was gonna have a moat and have
all kind of neat stuff doesn't have a
moment it's pretty neat place for those
of you look at Google because I could
continue to believe I continue to
believe so I've gone from the body oh
that's where my house used to be behind
that chain-link fence and you can see
between me and that brick wall isn't
very much space we had an 800 square
foot house I think that's 75 square
meter house even some of you probably
live in bigger houses than that and of
course there I am with my lovely wife on
my 75th birthday I needed a new
rolls-royce like I needed aids so what
did my wife gave me for my 75th birthday
a role just like the Queen has so when
we drive I go just like she does rule
number seven surround yourself with rich
people so you've got rich people right
most of you aren't hanging not chillin
for those people are you nope why you've
got all kinds of reasons why don't you I
didn't go to school but that's what I
got to say about all those reasons I
didn't either but somehow I weaseled my
way into people richer than that in a
good way because it was important to me
to change my life from being a barrio
bad boy who almost killed his teacher
when he was 12 years old
if success was important you would have
done something about it by now but it's
not too late it's never too late
rule number eight don't let failure stop
you success is like being pregnant
everyone says congratulations but nobody
knows how many times you go you have
three million pores in your body three
million and every one of them at least
twice in a bad way I have a young mentee
in the room who just recently got his
first and I'm not making light of rape
and like it but basically recently
almost got his first financial raping
here recently and I have a lot of scar
tissue because you know if I allow
people who disappoint me I'd never get
out of bed in the morning rule number
nine keep yourself in shape energy is in
here I happen to be an excellent
physical condition not if I'm 72 if I'm
32 I'm in an excellent state but I work
at it and I have worked at it since 1974
what is now called biohacking I started
being aware of my physical condition I
test my blood every six to eight weeks
I've got you know I told you yesterday I
wasn't joking about my testosterone
level the but I work at it and but when
I turned 60 I only drink when I'm
traveling now or at the seminars I don't
drink and I'm a vegan than when I'm at
home okay not because I believe in that
beacon horse but it I lose weight like
crazy when you're a vegan and real
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be obsessed when I
was in Poland as I said last yesterday
afternoon I talked about some very
successful kids and I said yeah yawn
stand up he's 22 years old he's
currently a student at a crack out of
university he made a million euros last
year which is no big deal to me but to
most you a million euros is a big deal
now one single student went up to ask
him what his name was
yawn what because if they did and he
told them the tip the see
secret the secret sauce they may feel
some responsibility to try to do it
themselves and then when they failed
then the you know most of the podcasts
most of the seminars most of the various
things that you study you're not
learning otherwise why you're still here
with the greatest respect of Michael
there's no reason when you leave here
today after the Q&A is over and I've
already told you everything's free on my
website I don't and when you see me in
the airport don't come up and talk to me
don't touch me I don't give a sh if you
live or die
my obsession is to drive as many of you
lazy bastards across the goal-line it's
humanly possible before I die that's it
if I have to hurt you spit on you call
your mother a [ __ ] I don't care now
I've got a special bonus rope from Dame
Pena on how to want it badly enough that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go
question number one how will you expose
yourself to more high performance people
number two
whose opinions do you need to stop
caring about and number three what
failure are you not going to let stop
you if you have no money you can make a
lot of money but for those of you they
have a few bucks it's easier it just is
because the motivated seller doesn't
have to be quite as motivated it's just
easier but III assume that everybody
comes to me with nothing a blank as
tabula rasa's decart said a blank tablet
but if you haven't liked the 17 year old
kid came to me with nothing who's flying
around in his goddamn jet now I mean he
came to me with nothing but the kid and
the reason why kids get it easier than
adults they have less baggage
they have less baggage when I told that
Josh did 99% of what I told me to do
exactly like I told him to do it exactly
and but I have other people that have
you know follow the precepts that are
old I mean not old I mean I'm probably
am i holding up - I'm trying enough to
be your father
no no no okay okay okay okay okay now
we're just gonna we're close yeah okay
but yeah I mean we've got guys the
oldest is 77 and the youngest is 1377
but I mean you gotta want it you gotta
win it and and not many people are
wanting to you know make the sacrifices
if you want more dane pain yeah check at
the top fifty rules video i made on him
the link is right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
adolf hitler might be the highest
performance guy that ever was born on
the planet when you decide that you
really want to invoke permanent change